keep your Aikido principles right so my
sender is low right we just start very
static very low and I want you to see
how I'm moving around the energy not
here like this I'm moving around the
energy and going from one control to the
other room and I'm affecting his center
by weight down see how I'm doing that
I'd never lose content I don't want this
you're gonna pop up and come on control
affect his center okay and then we'll do
the second part just the mechanics get
in position
tight control move it center again right
rule crane so slow go around the energy
get the mechanics part to move from your
Center hide it off
nice and smooth drilling okay
let's try on it my Mike Brown so he's
gonna try to push right it's just like
this drill okay so it's just Cherokees
trying to push and I'm grounding him
right then I'm gonna let the energy
right this is just easy me nakia same
thing so his energy he's pushing right
and I'm gonna let it go around pass it
to my armpit so same thing is I'm here
push you see I'm not getting compromised
sure so I need that face to send his
energy around in my armpit same thing he
pushes go right by the same thing I just
keep redirecting it into the ground so
all good warm around pool in so that he
ends up going into it if if you are
getting if your coke is getting over
power then apply some Mikey so he
started to overpower me but I want him
to go into it you see that I don't I
don't want to go here and then crank
like that I want him to fall into it so
the same thing whenever whenever I'm
touching right it has to it has to
affect his Center you don't push this
part right remember not though I have to
cool effect his Center so the same thing
when I come in here and you're going to
lift our don't squeeze his neck use his
Center against the weight of the of his
neck so I'm gonna get in it such a way
it's boom then I'm picking up his Center
and it's not it's just like any coaching
knocking it's a matter of balance of
putting the foam room where you needed
to be then then the guy's not heavy so
if I go out here he's gonna get heavy so
I have to be in a place where I'm gonna
lift his Center again
he will feel the same as Ronan
okay let's go see I'm on it I'm on this
thing is that I have a duty belt on
right so I can't go like this
and give him all that okay so it's it's
over I'm on I'm on the front of him
right and now I'm on the side of him you
see and if I cannot move but that wasn't
the opening but I go here first you see
and he's pushing it so I'd go see here
do you guys see that difference okay so
what I'm seeing as soon as you go like
this toe I got my baton am i again when
he feels like he's gonna get me he's
gonna grab for all that and I'm not
gonna keep doing this am i what am I
gonna do start protecting all that right
so you got a prioritize the my for
weapons then he's coming in and then I
can get this
and as he's starting to push on me right
and I'm doing this
look I'm stepping right he's still
pushing on me and I make that work
so your your basic was was here here and
then get the post in there and then
crank it but now I'm just gonna let him
do whatever he does so if I can't hit it
there right I'll go here because he's
push it and on if I can get it on one
step boom I'll hit it I might have to go
back though right same thing I had to go
back and get that person see how I'm
doing that I don't want to see this
stuff so here like kissing you that's
all muscle dang you want you want him to
hit it okay can you prioritizing
movement right so you're gonna be able
to tell ah man you got his chin in there
alright my chin Surratt dinner work
whatever you're gonna be able to tell
but you're threatening to threaten with
it
you understand so I'm not I'm not having
you not threatened with it so you're
going to threaten with it for ten right
and then BOOM so I'm here Emoto slow so
you see right always prioritizing weapon
placement I go here and you got his chin
in there I'm going to open it up so you
can see okay so I don't have his his
trachea you see but the other side of
his chin is available so when I know I
don't have that and he's pressing on me
right I'm gonna push this arm in like
that so I'm firing again he's pushing on
me
to your tactical priority okay so I have
to threaten I have to at anyone's our
Naga was that there was a was those
things set up each other if you do
something half-assed you're not going to
be as effective he has to defend one
that's what's setting up the the Naga
wasn't like any joke if I don't catch
him boom right there i ID prioritize
that because I have my weapons right so
I'm gonna give a serious attempt and if
I didn't catch him some loot I go right
for that one don't take two pumps okay
don't they're gonna go almost got it no
that's that's sport do you understand
so you're here he comes in right you're
trying to hit it there I didn't get it I
should be able to go in from there you
guess it cancel and not come in right
and I didn't hit it boop boop
okay do you guys understand that no
double pumps you either you either hit
him there and you got his weight working
against his trachea and is trotted on
the on the hole and if I don't
boom right I'm on to the next one there
you go
you need a serious attempt at Secchia
teens don't winter up my past arm low
get a base Tristen good get a base
breathe put it together roan and start
over you can go slow with life without
being staccato get you weight off your
heels you're too much on the line of
attacks you're on the line of attack
[Music]
Derek here he's pushing right
but here I'm worried so I started to
angle and he's coming back into me
that's which isn't that right I didn't
get it he's pushing it down and see I'm
also on you guys are if I'm on this line
here you guys are going like this keep
changing angles push push
change the angle please never let him
push on you all right pay attention that
line of attack so right he's trying to
get he's trying to get me so I'm moving
over here away from that arm and I aware
of this arm here okay and then he's
pushing on me so I go around here I try
for the pop but I still have the arm so
if he if I get the guillotine I'm still
cognizant of that arm I don't go like
this so I still am cognizant of what
that arm is doing which was why I don't
want her wrestle for I don't want to
finagle for it she has to hit it boom do
you see the armed ever was the issue do
you see that okay but now when I he
countered me and I have his arm there I
don't go like this cuz he's got me again
so their awareness on the arm goes to
the outside and passes it clears me
gives me in space over here on the
outside and I throw in touch okay so
make sure you're passing that arm let's
go